♪ ♪
NARRATOR: February 13th 2017.
Kuala Lumpur
International Airport.
Kim Jong-un's brother
enters the terminal,
unaware that two
female assassins are
also at the airport.
Now, for the first
time on television,
one of the assassins tells
her full extraordinary story.
MAN: Camera check.
NARRATOR: It begins with
her being recruited by a man
who claimed
to be a TV producer.
NARRATOR: For months,
Kim Jong-un's agents groomed
Siti and another young
woman to ambush unsuspecting
members of the public
and smother their faces
with cosmetic creams,
in what they thought were
hidden camera show stunts.
NARRATOR: Siti's handler
arranges a meeting
a café in the airport.
There she is to receive
details of the target.
NARRATOR: This time,
it isn't baby oil,
but a deadly nerve agent.
As Kim Jong-un's brother
heads to his flight,
the two women make their move.
NARRATOR: Seeking help,
Kim Jong-nam heads for the
airport's medical facility.
MADDEN (off-screen): So at this
point Kim Jong-nam is
in the infirmary,
and he is behind the door,
and this is where this
image gets very scary.
There's a
gentleman in all black,
walking near this door, okay,
and he's got a rolling suitcase.
He's checking in to make
sure that Kim Jong-nam is
receiving medical treatment.
This is one of the operatives.
It's a very
elaborate operation,
it's very old-school.
NARRATOR: The operation plays
out like a Cold War spy caper.
There are lookout men.
A chemist, to handle
the nerve agent.
A getaway driver.
And a team leader,
codenamed Grandpa.
The young women have no
idea what they've done.
(applause)
(sirens)
They are soon arrested
by the local Malaysian police.
(speaking in native language)
NARRATOR: The trial creates
shock-waves around the world.
TEIK: She had been charged
for the most serious
crime in the country,
the crime of murder.
For the offense of murder,
there's only one punishment,
and that is death, by hanging.
NARRATOR: The chemist of
the gang is also apprehended.
He is caught on camera
getting his story straight
with North Korean
embassy officials.
NARRATOR: This video evidence
helped to build a picture
of a ruthless political
assassination.
Both women were
released after spending
two years in prison.
NARRATOR: Kim Jong-un's
troublesome older brother
was no more.
Captioned by
Cotter Media Group.